[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul on this video we're
breaking down
m night shyamalan's new movie old
sorry had something stuck in my throat
there now m night is someone who i feel
i have to watch no matter what though i
don't always enjoy his movies
i think the director has done a great
job of creating situation horrors
that take a unique concept an audience
is dying to get to the bottom of
whether it's people being trapped in an
elevator during devil
or mother nature turning into
mother-in-law during the happening
each movie has an intriguing premise
that makes his films a must watch
even if more often than not they don't
deliver on their promise
old is no different and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the movie
it's plot and also the ending to discuss
exactly what happened in it
full spoilers ahead and though i
normally say if you haven't seen it that
you should check out now
i know some of you will be here without
watching the movie so you can learn what
the twist is
that's totally fine i won't judge you
and i hope you enjoy the breakdown
okay so how do you know if you're old
the candles cost more than the kkk it's
so weird i tell him now old starts off
simple enough
with married couple guy and prisca
taking their two kids trenton maddox on
a family vacation before they get
divorced
it turns out that prisca discovered she
had a tumor and she cheated on guy
though he never told her he knew this
the pair have decided to separate
but they want to give the children some
happy memories before things go
south guy is someone who always looks to
the future
and prisca always looks to the past and
their inability to live in the moment is
what drives a wedge between them
come the end of the film the pair
realized that they had one another and
that they should have focused on that
rather than external things
and it's quite a touching character arc
now at the resort trent befriends a
young boy named idlib
and he worries that trent is going to be
taken away so he writes him a coded
message
at the hotel they're told by the manager
named niels that there's a secret beach
area
and this is where the majority of the
movie takes place escorted there by an
unnamed character played by m knight
their gerry are tricked into taking part
in the experiment of a lifetime
that takes from the few in order to give
to the many after meeting several people
at the location
we see the phrase life's a beach and
then you die come into full effect
as everyone starts aging at a rapid pace
and this constant ticking clock in the
background adds to the desperation they
face
whilst trying to escape we discover that
the beach has a specific mineral in the
rocks that surround it which causes the
salt in someone's body to drastically
alter
because someone's hair and nails are
technically dead they don't change
however the rest of the body does along
with the mind this naturally occurring
anomaly is somewhat of a pressurized
location
and because the minerals cause one's
cells to change at a rapid pace
it's almost impossible to leave without
blacking out
now amongst the group is a rapper named
mid-sized sudan who has an issue with
his blood clotting
a family made up of a doctor called
charles who suffers from a mental
disease
his wife crystal who has a calcium
deficiency their daughter cara
mother agnes and cute little pooch
there's also jiren and patricia
the latter of whom suffers from epilepsy
after searching every nuke and granny
they come to the conclusion that time
isn't on their side and that there is no
escape during this they also figure out
that each family has a member with an
underlying health condition
which plays massively into the twist now
the movie as a whole i think feels very
much like a metaphor for life in general
though they try and fight their fate and
get away from the circumstances
time always catches up to them old age
is something that will come to us all if
we live long enough
and nothing we do can stop the hands of
time because of this the situation feels
rather hopeless at points
and it's not too long before we learn
that this is all part of a process
whilst the first half of old is about
the characters trying to escape their
fate
the latter is about them accepting it
and trying to see the good in life
rather than the bad the movie is based
on the graphic novel sandcastle
and in that we hear the story of a
character who was so afraid of death
that he spent most of his life trying to
avoid it
this fear consumed him to the point that
he didn't live life to the fullest
and i do think that this is an important
message for an audience
even if the execution in the movie
leaves a lot to be desired
now trent maddox end up discovering a
notebook of someone else who was stuck
on the beach before them
and it details that there was an unknown
individual watching them throughout
their time
now it turns out that these observers
are all part of an experiment carried
out by a research group
who wish to advance medical technologies
in order to treat the sick and
vulnerable
we discover that the hotel itself is a
front that's merely used to usher people
into trials as
no one would ever willingly volunteer to
give the rest of their life up
on the off chance a treatment might work
drug trials typically tend to take
decades to see the results of
and the beach actually allows the
research team to speed up the
observation process
so that they can learn a lifetime's
worth of knowledge in the space of a day
the pharmaceutical company recruit
people whilst they're trying to get
their prescriptions
and upon arriving at the hotel they're
given specialized drinks
which all contain certain medicines
these people are then grouped together
in the hopes that one will provide a
breakthrough and in the film we learn
that 73 sets of people have gone through
this experiment
now because of the trial we see the
science group managed to find a way to
treat epilepsy
and thus it is viewed as a success this
development will allow people across the
world who suffer from
it to have better medical care and the
movie is very much
arguing whether the ends justify the
means i'm sure the scientists think that
they are morally justified in carrying
out these experiments in order to help
others
but the torture that the people trapped
on the beach go through is agonizing to
watch
there are several members in each family
that don't have anything wrong with them
and they're sent to the beach for no
reason other than to make those being
experimented on
not have any suspicions we ourselves as
an audience very much become like the
scientists
watching this thing play out we observe
the characters as they age
i wonder why we wasted 108 minutes of
our lives
with this piece of crap i'm just i'm
just kidding the movie was all right now
on the beach after several failed escape
attempts tensions start to rise
and we discover that charles has a
paranoid mental condition which slowly
starts to get worse and worse
i've seen some people say that this is
schizophrenia whilst others have said
it's dementia
i don't want to be disrespectful as both
are serious conditions that i don't
think should be demonized
either way he kills mid-sized sedan and
the rest of the people on the beach
slowly succumb to either attempting to
escape or their conditions
there's a horrifying scene in which kara
has a rapid pregnancy
and some moments are truly shocking it
all comes to a head and charles attempts
to attack
guy but after he's slashed with a rusty
knife left behind by other victims
the character gets blood poisoning at
super speed it's a twisted way for
everything to play out
and leaves the core family as the only
survivors now before passing away
guy and prisca bury the casket with one
another and guys somewhat forgives her
as he realizes he can't even remember
what they were fighting about in the
first
place guy says he's just happy they
could all be together
and this entire journey they've been on
feels like a time lapse of a marriage
in the end he can't even remember why
they wanted to leave the beach
and he dies with his family surrounding
him it's pretty heartbreaking and it's
arguably the strongest part of the movie
as we know he's doomed to his fate but
he still manages to see the good in life
i guess the trip of a lifetime turned
out to be just that and he dies after
saying he's not angry with prisca
anymore
prisca walks towards the sea before
passing away and maddox and trent have
to watch their parents die
which is likely something that will
happen to us all the pair fall asleep
and they awaken to find themselves much
older and they decide to try and escape
again however they want to take a moment
to just have some fun
and the pair build a sand castle
together on the beach which is of course
a call back to the aforementioned
graphic novel
now from here trent decodes a message
that was given to him by nils's nephew
and this actually leads them to
realizing that there is a way to escape
the pressure doesn't affect the coral
around the location and thus they're
able to swim through it
and make it off the beach above the
cliffs we see m knight who was observing
them
and he believes that they've drowned
after they fail to resurface
he calls us in and whoever's on the
other end it seems like he wants him to
stay and make sure
but he quickly reminds him that the last
person who made it out died shortly
after anyway
m knight then travels to the lab which
is where we learn the truth about what's
really going on there
and the new treatment for epilepsy
however it's revealed that trent and
maddox survived
and they actually swam through the coral
which allowed them to escape
armed with the journal of the person who
was on the beach before them
they go to policemen that they met when
they were younger and expose the
operation
this leads to the employees of the hotel
being arrested
and everything is seemingly shut down
the pair must adjust to their new life
and changes but maddox says that things
will be alright
now as for the experiments and how they
wrap up it's an ending that will
obviously have a lot of people arguing
over whether what they did was right as
it was for the greater good
but it ruined so many people's lives
that you pretty much
can't justify it the film is a bit of a
weird one
and like a lot of m nights work there's
no clear cut right and wrong
and overall it's a pretty depressing
analogy of life
people will use you and spit you out
whilst you attempt to fight for what's
most important to you
and the metaphor of being trapped
somewhere whilst you age can
be applied to a number of things whether
it's your job
your relationship or even watching
terrible youtubers explain movies to you
i think the point of the movie is to
make us realize that we all have a
finite amount of time
and that we shouldn't waste it life is
precious and sadly a lot of the
characters on the island
learn this lesson too late which leads
to them dying
filled with regret it's not a nice fate
and though i think the movie could have
handled a lot of elements better than it
did
the film does have a strong message to
it what did i think of it overall
well before we get into the review part
of the video i want to let you know
we're giving away three free mcu box
sets at the end of the month
and all you have to do is comment below
like the video and make sure that you
subscribe with notifications on
i'll be choosing the winners at random
on the 30th of july and the lucky people
who got the last ones are on screen
right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers
now as for my thoughts on the film it
was something that i really really
wanted to like
but due to the handling of the material
and certain directional choices
i think that it misses the mark at
certain points now i'm not someone who
just outright hates m knight and his
work
i think the sixth sense and unbreakable
are masterpieces
i really enjoy the servant as well and
actually got given early access to the
first episode of the second season
which contained an exclusive video from
the director
in which he basically talked about what
went into the show he said that he tries
to add some dark humor to his work
as it can be unnerving for an audience
to wonder whether something is supposed
to be funny or not
if he's sitting there and not knowing if
he can laugh it can lead to some
nervousness during a scene
but often i find that doing that leads
to said scene
feeling totally disjointed there were
points in this film where i was trying
to figure out whether something was a
joke or not
and it made it really weird to watch
there were audible laughs in the
audience when things were supposed to be
serious
and i'm not sure if that was the
intention but it feels like a fail to me
now on top of this the shot choices were
also very strange
and though it gave a claustrophobic feel
at points there were moments where
it was just a strange way to film things
i get that it was supposed to get you
off balance but i don't know if it
worked every time
and i'm probably a boring person that
likes more standard cinematography
often the camera would just pan away
from what was going on for a long time
and you kind of felt like you were
missing some great performances
so saying that i don't really think the
movie worked all that well
but in the same sentence i will say that
this is a film that will stick with you
the performances were all really good
and the casting was perfect
especially with all the different ages
they do some incredible things with
subtle makeup touches
and overall it's really well made it was
a hell of a journey full of ups and
downs
and sort of like life in a way i suppose
you know full of ups and downs
highs and lows but we got there in the
end now i have mixed feelings on the
film but i do feel that the good
outweighs the bad
and in the end i think it'll be
something that people talk about for a
long time
i feel the horror was really well
handled such as the rapid fire birth
and crystal's calcium deficiency which
leads to her getting a hunchback
the film script also works really well
on a second viewing
and there's several mentions of things
that pay off like the hunchback
and the rusty knives which i think
actually makes the movie better on
repeat viewings
m night keeps on m knighting and you'll
probably know before going into this
whether it's something that you like or
not
i think it ranks around lady in the
water and maybe the village for me in
terms of direction
and overall it gets a 6.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and whether you
agree or disagree
i think that the film is gonna have
people split hey and if you have
anything you want to add
then drop it in the comments below if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the easter eggs in space jam
a new legacy as it took a while to do
and i just i would just appreciate the
support
and without the way thank you for
sending you the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time
take care peace